before marriage used to be something
that was you would give somebody
something because they would give me
something Virginia Chastity you know
they were but now I think marriage has
to be something as a reward for a woman
now it's before it was like it was a
gift it was like yeah but now it's a
reward so you have the baby first you
live the life first and then reward you
marriage because how can what are you
actually getting do you understand what
I'm trying to say to you so if I believe
in marriage right but we can't be giving
we have to reward you with marriage now
so I'm going to marry you I would have
you if you was a virgin but you're not a
virgin now
there's some things that we might need
to change now right